Hello and welcome to today's episode. This is
Rawkode live. I'm your host Rawkode.
Today, we're gonna be taking a look at
Falco,
a security run time for Kubernetes with the
magic of EBPF.
I don't really know what that means, but
fortunately I have two wonderful guests who do.
Leo DiDonato and Lorenzo Fattana, two former colleagues
of mine at my days from influx data,
now working as engineers at Sysdig and maintainers
of the Falco project.
Before we bring them in, I wanna thank
my employer, Equinix Medal. They provide the time
for me to work on the show and
produce content to hopefully educate and help us
all learn this very vast and complicated cloud
native landscape.
If you want to try Equinix Metal yourself,
you can use the code Rawkode live. This
will get you $50 of compute time.
That can get you roughly
a hundred hours of a sixty six ninety
six giga ram machine
with 28 cores or you can splurge it
all in five hours with hundreds of gigs
of ram, 400 gig of ram and three
terabytes of disk. So you know, take that
take that $50 and use it wisely or
unwisely. That is up to you.
Now, I am going to bring in my
wonderful guest for today.
Lorenzo. Hey.
Nice to see you. There we go. How
are you both doing?
So far so good.
We are
really into some
new things for Falco at the moment, but
everything's fine.
Aside from the fact that everyone is buying
into our houses
here in Italy again
as everyone else in the in the world.
Alright. Well, why don't you I enjoyed your
music, honestly.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Like, I don't know. I
keep meaning to make a joke about it.
Like, the intro and the outro are quite
quite energetic,
and then there's me, which is, like, way
down here in the energy kind of space.
So the better polarity, but, you know, I
I like it. It's good. So why don't
we start with Lorenzo? Do you wanna just
introduce yourself?
And then we'll move over to Leo, and
then we'll talk about Falco.
Yeah. Well, I'm Lorenzo Fontana.
My nickname is unpronounceable, so I'm not going
to pronounce it.
Just read it. And I'm
working at Sysdig,
and Sysdig is sponsorship.
Mine and Rawkode works on Falco
to be the maintainers of Falco and to,
you know, help Falco becoming
some more, you know, stable and adding features.
And also, you know, with, hopefully,
having Git graduated in CNCF after reaching the
incubation last year.
I'm also the author of the Hooks of
SurveyMedi with with David Calavera for Riley,
if you want to check out that book.
And I'm doing a lot of work
recently,
with my friend Leo
and with others,
and that's it.
Leo, to you.
Okay. So it's
my name is Leonardo DiDonato.
As Lorenzo said, I'm an open source an
open source software engineer at Sysdig,
where, basically, our daily jobs is to code
Falco, maintain it, and all of it. So,
yes, we spend all the day on GitHub,
which is something that we love. And
basic basically, you can find me in the
web verse with nickname that I put here,
Ledido, over Twitter, over GitHub. My
daily duties are very similar to Lorenzo's
one. So, basically, we're we're in charge of
coding Falco,
which is a c plus plus project,
but also to maintain other parts of Falco
that that makes possible
to detect security threats at runtime,
namely
Libsys,
and
the drivers of Falco that at at the
moment, have, like, three drivers, a kernel module
and a BPF probe one and user space
one based on Big Trace,
Ackery, Wizardry.
Great stuff.
Yeah. I mean, I understand some of the
words. So, I mean, we're making progress here.
Can we We we don't even understand them
words.
Yeah. I mean, you said c plus plus,
and I was like, oh, dear. Like,
that takes me way back. I haven't written
a line of c plus plus in a
long time. Although I do keep up with
the changes to the language and it's looking
really more impressive these days with some of
the newer changes. So
Yeah. Let's talk about Falco then.
What are the primary use cases for Falco?
Why should people have Falco running on their
cluster?
Go.
You wanna go or
I I go.
You can complement.
Leo keeps me sane usually. This is one
of also of Leo's duty, I mean, keeping
me alive. So
Falco is, you know, kind of simple,
but also, you know, somewhat complicated.
Basically, you use it to be alerted
when something bad happens in your cluster. This
is a very basic explanation,
very high level explanation. So let's say someone
spawns a shell or someone,
know, creates a privileged pod or someone creates
a config map in Kubernetes with, you know,
some, credential that should not be there, like,
you know, AWS credential or,
Equinix credential, these kind of things.
Someone
she modified,
they should not be she mod, or someone
gets root access to something, or someone manages
to,
you know, get a root shell somewhere where
it should not be allowed to.
This is all done via
a thing that we call Falco rules,
and they are just expressed in YAML
because, you know, everything is YAML.
And
so you just write some YAML,
and out of that YAML, you get some
nice alert messages
for when something happens. The value of Falco
is not just, you know, the code that,
you know, processes the YAML and gives you
the alerts, but the community also puts a
lot of effort into
creating a same default rule set
for, you know, the vast majority of the
people out there. So you can create your
own rules. You can make rules, you know,
adapt to your organization and your needs.
But by default, we ship a default rule
set, which should be, you know, good enough
for most of the use cases.
That's what I had to do.
Can I add a bit?
Yeah. Please. Please, sir. Basically,
just like an introduction, more more generic.
If we look a way to better position
Falco in the security landscape I mean, if
we look at the security landscape,
we could simplify it into, basically,
two parts, prevention and detection.
Both of the parts have one thing in
common, which is policies, which is another cool
name that we could give to Falco rules.
And the difference is that while
prevention
tools
use those policies to change the behavior
of processes by preventing Cisco's to happen or
stopping processing to to execute and things like
that.
On the other side on the other end,
the policies detection tools use policies to monitor
the behavior and notify a a user
when
the behavior of a process steps outside of
the policy,
which means that Falco,
differently from other tools like Secom, Secom BPF,
app app armor is poses the Falco position
is on the detection side of the security
landscape,
which does not mean that you should only
use Falco or you should only use prevention.
Basically, the best approaches in the security is
to use a debt defense in that, which
means stacking different tools with different strategies, some
for prevention and some for detection together to
achieve
satisfactory
level of security,
which, by the way, will not all will
not be perfect in any case.
So this is where we can position Falco
to make clear maybe to the to the
audience
that different from other tools like AppArmor,
Secop, and things like that,
it positions
on the detection side,
especially for cloud native environment like the Kubernetes
based ones,
which is a a field that's
where security, I mean, should
yeah. Should be solved yet. There there's only
Falco and nothing
more to as far as I know.
Alright. Yeah. I mean We call it container
runtime security.
Yep. Yeah. That makes sense to me then.
Like, I I like the, you know, defense
and death. We should be using our Palmer
sec comp, all these things to restrict what
our containers can do. But, inevitably, things can
and will go wrong, and Falco is what
we use inside of our clusters or or,
I guess, it doesn't doesn't need to be
in a cluster. Can it just run on
on Linux? Like Yeah. It's going to you
can also run on
theoretically, that theoretically, that's the preferred way to
run Falco on the host. The only cluster.
So we are on Falco on our host.
It's gonna use e b p f and
some other drivers. It's gonna alert to us
when things happen that we want to be
aware of. And then Yeah. From that, we
can then react to that. We can then
decide how we want to handle that information.
Sometimes it may just be,
notifications,
like someone
pseudo or whatever. I don't know what the
capabilities are, but we'll look into that shortly.
But I get it. That makes sense.
Alright. Let's tackle. We got a couple of
comments, so I'll just run through those quickly.
Oh, there's someone.
So Robin says, you've been enjoying the streams.
Thank you very much, Robin. They're gonna keep
coming because I love to sound in my
own voice.
Alison is saying, looking forward to learn more
about Falco. Me too.
Definitely one of those things that seems scary
and I'm hoping that you two are gonna
make this easy for me to understand.
And at Kakaran,
bloody YAML, I think we are all
we all have that same sentiment.
Yeah. We all have that sentiment, but I
still prefer YAML to
second policies. So I have a few And
also processing YAML in Go is, I think,
processing YAML in c plus plus, different
league. It's a whole new level.
I mean, as much as we rant about
YAML, I think we all do in the
cloud native space because there's so much of
it. It's really, I mean, besides the edge
cases, it's really easy for people to pick
up and learn like, you know, there are
a lot of benefits as well. We shouldn't
maybe be too quick to judge it. But
anyway,
let's get started.
This is gonna be interesting
because I had some homework to do upfront
and I'm hoping I've not messed that up.
So
if anyone wants to learn more about Falco
after today's session,
it is open source, you can go to
github.com/falcosecurity/falco.
Today's servers are provided by my employer Equinix
metal. I have spun up using the cluster
API, which is just amazing. My own Kubernetes
cluster,
and I have some backup resources here that
I think I'm gonna need when it comes
to doing some of the Falco stuff. That
was my homework that I failed to do.
Regardless,
we do have a running Kubernetes cluster, which
should still be running.
There's always that moment of fear. But yes,
we have a nine one nineteen two
Kubernetes cluster. We are running Ubuntu 20.
Now, there were some prerequisites from you both
regarding to what I needed in this cluster.
Can we maybe just discuss why we
why we're worried about the operating system version
being Ubuntu? Why we're worried about the Kubernetes
version? What are some of those prereqs?
So
very quickly,
Falco
is very tied to the kernel.
Right?
So
we are trying to make the Falco experience
very you know, to be very good on,
you know, most of the kernels,
most of the distributions.
It's very easy for us to be very
working very well on newer kernels
because
you have a couple of options to run
Falco. I mean, the, you know,
real options. We have, you know, the new
user space option which which is, you know,
still under heavy development,
which should be solving the problems that, you
know, I'm talking about. But the option that
you have are are essentially the kernel module
and the eBPF pro. Right? So the eBPF
program is solely on very new kernels, as
well on very new kernels.
And the kernel module runs from kernel, like,
two dot six to, you know, newer kernels.
This means that you have to compile
a kinda module or compile a BPF probe
because both, you know, rely on a stable,
API from the kernel.
So they cannot be compiled once run everywhere
yet. Right? So you just have to compile
for kind of where you are.
The Falco
community
tries to package a Falco in a way
that you you don't have to worry about
that. And
the way that we package that is, you
know, the usual RPM and dev based packages.
So if you install from those, it should
be installed smoothly, and you shall just should
just work.
If you install from a container,
like, QCTL run QCTL apply something
where, you know, a Falco container is running.
Like, you use your our own chart or
you use our YAML definitions.
It will use a Falco docker image, Falco
container image,
that will
need to figure out the kernel and compile
the kernel module, the BPF pro for you.
Right? Okay.
If it can't,
we have a web server where we ask
thousands
of compiled kernel module in VP of probes
for thousands of different kernel combinations.
So you are trying.
You can go to downdownload.falco.org
to to count all the the the page
drivers.
And
this is very I mean, just quick driver
and other should QA is the latest.
So this is very
this is very useful,
but
what happens is that
for common operating systems, we pay more attention
to it. Like, for Ubuntu 20,
for
US Fedoras,
Centos,
for very widely used of our thesis. We
did a survey, and it turned out that,
you know, people use Ubuntu, Fedora, Centos
Amazon Linux. Amazon Linux. A lot of Amazon
Linux is probably our, you know, most used,
image,
and the others. So we try to keep
up with that. We have a lot of
Yam every every one of them is a
YAML file.
So, yeah, more YAMLs
for the comments.
So if you want to compile if you
want us to provide a precompile
for your specific combination,
you open up a request with a YAML
file, and our build system keeps that takes
it and compile the Falco driver for that
one. The current module or the BPF probe
or bus? Yeah. The current module. Depends on
if it can.
And you put it on this downloads
repository.
So we are trying to, you know, make
sure. But for this demo because, you know,
the demo gods are not always good.
We just said, oh, work to 20 should
work. Maybe it doesn't,
but
sure. We'll see.
So
to summarize that, it it wasn't actually a
prerequisite. It was just to simplify things for
today's session. If if you want to use
other operating systems, it's always an option. You
just may have to compel the drivers of
yourself. That's it. I okay.
Yeah. I think I get that. That makes
sense.
So let's That's the last resort we want
you to have. But
hopefully
I'm sure things things are on their side.
Yeah. Yeah. We'll be fine. Okay. So I
should I pull up the docs? That would
probably be the first step. Right?
Exactly.
Yes.
Alright.
So
we have a Kubernetes cluster. I have access
to all of the machines.
So
I'm assuming you mentioned earlier that we're gonna
apt get install Falco.
It's kinda what I'm seeing here too. So
am I just gonna go ahead and add
this repository.
Right?
Yeah. We have two. As I said, we
have two ways of installing Falco. Maybe, Leo,
you want to give a reason why we
are suggesting apt?
Well,
this way, we're
this way, we'll install Falco on Diosk. I
don't I I'm it's not clear to me
if we want to install Falco on Diosk,
which is the recommended way or if we
want to install it with something like Alcharts.
I will go with everything because the experience
is
way cleaner in my opinion. And also I
agree. Architecturally,
that's the place where the Falco should be
in the host. Yeah. Otherwise
Sorry. Sorry.
It's very
what what do they want to say? Maybe
I'm just saying it for him.
Is that Falco is a very foundational component
in an infrastructure
because
it actually, you know, makes sure that nothing
happens
in the host. Right? We are also doing
steps to make sure that Falco boots
as fast as possible in a system,
like, even maybe, if possible,
like, exactly when the kernel boots at some
point
because Falco
needs to see everything. I mean, if someone
put a rootkit in your unit 30,
you're not gonna have Kubernetes booted up in
your unit 30.
Right?
So, for example,
so we are, you know, encouraging users
to always deploy Falco at the same level
they deploy, you know, their other,
machine component that they use for, like, the
queue the cubelet or the CNI plugin. So
it's at same level
so that they
so that Falco can take over and, you
know, understand everything that's happening. You can still
deploy Falco in Kubernetes.
Right now, it doesn't have, you know, any
differences in features.
But in the future, we want to make
sure that Falco, you know, takes over more
components. So we are, you know, suggesting that.
Also,
if you install Falco in Kubernetes, that means
that
if someone access your Kubernetes cluster, you know,
unauthorizedly,
they can stop Falco,
like, immediately from every node that you have.
And that's not good because Falco is there
for
Or worse, they can leave it
running but removing
rules. So you will not notice. You will
go, okay. Everything is fine. Falco is not
for triggering any rule, any alert, and that's
because they disabled the the rules at all.
So that's You know, worse.
I Yeah. Yeah. That's that's makes sense. You
know, Kubernetes is great. Containers are great for
most workloads. But if we're integrating and talking
the kernel, we're providing security concerns, like, running
this on the host seems to me like
it should be the right way forward. So
yeah. Let's And also,
not many people want to run a privileges
container in a cluster, and Falco would be
one because it does no other way.
So so
It's broadcast.
So that should
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I know this is gonna
be a pain for people to read, but
all I'm doing is copy and pasting the
command. So we've added our Falco repository.
We need the Linux headers because we're compiling
a kernel module or installing a kernel module,
I would imagine.
And then we install Falco. And
that should be it.
You're really mastering this science, David.
Yeah. It's it's always start off strong and
it goes down fast. Don't worry. Like
so
that's it. Okay. That's just other
distributions.
So
does the a bunch of package do the
driver installation, or do I still need to
run through these steps here? It should be
already done. You can check that out with
LS mod
pipe grep Falco.
Alright.
So mod probe Falco?
Oh, wait. You probably didn't do a p
t install Falco.
I did. Oh, yes. Oh, yes. It's it's
there. Okay. Okay. Okay. I just had to
mod probe it, and all of the machines
now have Falco returning on Alice mods. But
I think that's a win. If you just
see the CTL start Falco,
it will it will have done the mod
probe for you.
Yeah. Just we didn't start it.
Of course. Test on the all the things.
I always forget. Okay.
So that Let's verify let's verify. Okay. PSOX.
Okay?
If you run Oh my gosh. It's working.
Yeah. If you run journal
CTL
dash f
f u, Falco,
we should see something.
I feel like you just told me to
go fuck myself. Yeah.
Fuck. Yeah. No. Sorry.
No. That's so that's what
That's another way to see it.
Okay. And you will see that Falcon already
showing you something.
I see something. Yep. Okay. Yep. I think
it
we're good. It's running. Okay? We is that
do you wanna run anything else? Is there
anything else that's gonna give you a bit
more confidence? Or we We can do like,
before we dive into Kubernetes or we see
anything else, I will love for us to
analyze
what Falco's saying.
Looks like you're running Calico.
Yep. And, you know, Calico is totally, you
know, a good workload here because you installed
it.
And but Falco is complaining because it's a
privileged container
and has been started by the image Calico
node v three one five three.
It looks like we don't have an exclusion
for Calico. Right? We try to do as
much exclusions as we
are able to, but we don't, you know,
find we don't have exclusions for all the,
you know, software that should be excluded.
So if someone is listening
and they want to, you know, do a
contribution,
just go to our rules file in the
Falco repository
under the rules folder
and make an exclusion for Calico. It would
be very good as a first contribution.
And
if you want to try something just to
see, you know, what Falco can do, go
to the TMP folder and create a file.
Alright. Like, touch or
read to file in t m p. Alright.
Can I ask a question first then? Yeah.
Sure.
So that this is Why are we here?
So
this is visible to people. Do I have
any more commands I need to broadcast, or
can I close these other tabs?
Okay. So we don't
have to do anything, but we probably want
to configure the
Kubelet,
the Kube API servers of the machines Alright.
Later. I'll just grab the IP address of
this note then and get a new tab.
Yeah. Maybe.
If you want. If you are able.
Yeah. That's fine. I'll keep the I'll keep
the splits here because I we may have
to do other stuff and the rules fail
itself may have to show up. Okay. So
let's jump on this box.
Now what we were seeing there was so
that yeah. This is the line here. So
Falco is running. As noticed, we have a
privileged container and Yeah. Okay.
And what as Falco is saying here, we're
starting an internal web server
because
we, by default, start the web server,
which exposes a cube API
server
webhook
endpoint
for the audit logs,
and
you can configure a cube API server to
send hooks to that. But before we dig
we dive into that,
I will love you to, you know, try
to make Falco angry.
Yeah.
Let's create a Lorenzo file here.
Okay. And
then g mod g plus s Lorenzo.
Save save this file. Also, empty it's no.
Change mode to on the file. Yeah. Just
change mode the file.
Set the suite d group ID g g
plus s.
Plus s. Plus
s, Lorenzo.
Okay. Now if you go to the Falco
outputs,
you should see
another triggered.
Uh-huh.
Look. Now this set to your set to
the beat is set via c mod, and
it tells you everything that he knows. That
the file name was the MP Lorenzo,
the flags that have been set, the user
that
did the operation and other things like that.
The the exact command line, she mod g
plus s Lorenzo.
And in this case, container ID is sourced
because we are running this operation on the
host,
not in a container. But if you do
the same, like starting a container, an Alpine
one, for example,
and the second
exponer shell in the container and you do
the same thing, Falco detects it. In that
case, it will give you the container ID
of the container where you did that operation
that malicious operation.
Exactly. And also shows you before telling you
that, tells you, hey. Someone started a container
with root shell, and they are doing comments,
and the comment is this one. Yeah. Let's
try. Maybe it's better if we try it.
So
Okay. So what's the docker run run
IT Alpine.
Docker. Alpine
3.9.
Do do dash do dash IT.
Yeah. Yeah. Something like
Oh, this connection is very fast.
Okay. Cool.
So, like,
you can you can edit a file in
the bin in the bin
directory, or you could you could redo the
TMP, Laurens, a thing.
Or you can Maybe maybe try to
create a file in the BIM directory
with whatever you want
and just save it and then go out.
Just touch just touch the file without anything.
And if you do APK like you were
doing, it will also see, hey. Someone spawned
the package manager.
Yep. Okay.
Like
So just touching that file, and then you
want me to drop out the container and
look at the Falco logs again. Yep. Yep.
Yeah. Love the comments. It's read. I love
the comment I just said. I love how
Leo is sat here like I wanna type.
Yeah. It's always like that.
Okay.
So Falco
internal
Cisco event drop. So it
so what what does this one mean? What
does it mean by the one system call
was dropped in last second? That in some
cases, this is something
that we are really been
trying to solve, and we improved that a
lot. Basically,
as Lorenzo say
we're saying
ten minutes before,
we are using Ciscos, which which are the
main interface that we have to the Linux
kernel.
And the problem is that Cisco's are a
lot. They change very often, so it's very
hard to keep Falco track.
But, also, they happens at a rate that
sometimes is very, very difficult to keep up.
So in some cases, for various reasons that
can depends on the the throughput of Cisco,
the amount of Cisco's that are happening on
the machine,
or, at the same time, issues with the
page the memory pages and things like that,
we can experience and detect some drops. So
we can experience that we have not received
some input events on Falco, so we could
not
know what happened in that only in that
exact instant.
But
this basically is dropping, like, what what? One
system calls in the last second. In a
second,
can also happen one or two millions of
Cisco's.
I mean
so
okay. We will fix it. We will try
to avoid this to bring this number down
to zero, but
this is what what the backlog
tells us. What we are really interested here,
we about the
the experiment that we were doing, yes, is
that line. File below a non binary directory
open for writing,
touch by doctor, file being by doctor. So
it detects it and Yeah. You can reconstruct
the whole story. Right? If you go notice,
privilege container started
as first event after web server.
And then notice at the so with the
GDB, which is what we did before. And
then notice a shell was spawned in a
container.
And this is was the a s h
shell that you spawned,
and it tells you the image and the
container ID. Right?
Then,
you know, that's the drop. But then it
immediately keeps up
and, you know, shows that you just, you
know, created the file.
So it gives you a kind of, you
know, history of what happened so that you
can reconstruct
the whole attack
payload and
see what happened during the session of the
attacker. Yep. Also, in this case, David, as
you as we were mentioning before, we have
the container ID and the image name
differently from the past experiment
that was telling us container ID host
because it was run on the host.
Exactly.
Okay.
So
the one thing that I'm I'm kinda thinking
about now, like,
haven't configured any rules. So can you is
this a default rule then? If we create
something on a known binary directory, it's gonna
trigger on it. What what are some of
the default rules? Can we look at Good
question.
Yeah. If you go to h c Falco.
Yes. I love it when stuff's just intuitive.
It's like, I just I I just thought
it's definitely gonna be there. So Yeah.
Just
it's DG path.
And so you have Falco YAML where all
the default Cisco rules are. You have Falco
you have Kate Savit rules YAML
where all the rules for the Kubernetes,
we didn't use it yet.
And your Falco rules local,
where you can add your own rules without
the package system to override them, or you
can create,
you know, multiple files in rules default.
A couple of options. Rules
dot d. Yep. Rules dot d. Yes. We
are also working on a system to
enable people
to cruise from the outside, like, from distributed
system, like, you know, it's CD or Kubernetes,
and
also, like, reload them
Yeah. Which is something that we go in
the next features. The next That is
that is what we were working before entering
this stream.
Yeah.
Alright. So
let me see what we have here. Okay.
So this is the Falco configuration, but the
the default rules are
Yeah. Sorry. This one.
If I if I could type. So rules.
YAML. You can type YAML.
Yeah.
Okay. So we got
Wait a minute. Wait a wait a minute.
Since since we are here,
Falco rules is YAML,
but, basically, we built
a language, let's call a language,
on top of the off top of the
I was on YAML features.
For example, we you
can define Falco rules using
macros. So you can also define macros to
later reuse them in different rules. For example,
here we have some macros that are specifically
being created to
detect open Ciscos,
open read, open write. You can do the
same, and we have for exec v,
another Cisco that's
usually used to run executables.
You can also create lists
that you can use to exclude or include
a list of topics. For example, I will
exclude Calico, this other and this other this
other CNI plug in because I know that
they are okay to run-in my Kubernetes cluster.
So I will create a list with the
all the name of the CNI plug ins
in ages and exclude them in a in
a in that rule that we were talking
about before.
Soon, we are also implementing a mechanism
for exceptions in rules,
but the Falco default rule set tries
to cover the most common
threats, the most common use cases. And
since it's
checked in the GitHub repo, everyone, and this
is very common, can contribute to it and
help us to keep it on track with
new new tools, new methodologies,
new things, and so keeping the rules updated
day by day. Anyway, if you scroll.
If you want to have, like, an example
of what you did before, you can search
for privileged,
and you will see the rule
that
privilege it. Yeah.
Search for privileged container started.
Yes.
Exactly. Launch privilege of container. This is what
triggered when you
started Calico
in your
in your cluster.
Okay. So Yeah.
Here, there's container started. There's a macro sorry.
Go.
No. I mean, you're I I was gonna
just guess what I think it means, but
I'm more than happy for you just to
walk us through that. So if you wanna
run through the conditions, that's that's all good.
Yeah. The
is what I we were saying before. Basically,
the to provide this rule to become, like,
a a flow of if a a flow
of conditions,
basically, we
used some macro here. Container started
and container
and container privilege is true, which is a
field. In this case, this is not a
macro, and not Falco privileged containers and not
user privileged containers,
which are true lists, which means that you
can pull you can
put something in the user privileged containers list
to exclude
that thing to trigger this this rule. At
the same time,
you can go and look at the container
start at the macro or at the container
macro. If you search for macro,
colon, space, container,
you will reach the
column,
micro
double column. I don't remember how to call
it English.
No. One. Sorry. Column space
container.
Space.
Yeah.
There we go. Nope.
Really they already want to type.
Yeah. I
okay. Yeah. So as you can imagine, this
this this model is very simple.
If container ID is not us, as we've
seen with the two examples,
that means we are in con we we
are in a container and not in in
The Us.
And so that evaluates to true.
At the same time, container started checks
the event type. It's exactly.
And
that
basically, the we have the container image
name
complete.
Yeah. Okay.
I think we have a question, which I
believe it's interesting. Cool rules come from OPA
tool?
Yep.
Interesting question.
It's a very interesting question. And the question
is interesting because
the work that
I mentioned before that Liran and I are
doing, you know, like, today
is explicitly
to
allow
external implementations
to load rules into Falco. What I mean,
that we will have a default implementation of
our rule loader that we go, like, on,
you know, files, Kubernetes,
you know, whatever we
find the default means.
But, you know,
either the Falco project or anyone can create
a Falco rule loader
that watches something
and load rules in Falco. OPA is a
very, you know, good use cases use case
for that because,
you know,
it's, you know, what you express in OPA,
and, you know, it's very, you know, how
to say
it's very expressive, and it's also very
generic.
So you can express, you know, a condition
that resembles the Falco rules and then create
the Falco rules and load them in Falco.
All these kind of use cases are exactly
why we are developing that.
And
I believe that at some point, something like
this will will happens once we have this,
this thing.
If you
believe that this is important for you, I
will love to see you
in our community calls,
to define maybe
some more details.
Because what does, you know, what does that
mean? At some point, it's just, you know,
what do the user expect,
and I'm not a user of Falco.
So I will just, you know, love to
talk with some users about that.
Okay. Just for anyone who's not familiar, Opa
is open policy agent. And if you want
an introduction to that, I do have an
episode scheduled for the November 18. So feel
free to tune in for that one too.
That's a question.
Yeah. That was a really good question.
Okay.
Let's
let's move on then. So we've got our
Falco rules. Do we get all these default
rules by default? They monitor things, the containers
being run as privileged. They monitor for binaries
and no one,
know, privileged direct, not privileged, but where we
keep binaries. So we have
plask stuff, SSH stuff, like, so it seems
like you're just you're casting a wide net
here with regards to what we think could
be potentially dangerous and then giving people alerts
on that information.
And if I scroll to the bottom, we
had 3,000
lines of YAML. So Do do you want
to know a very funny story about Falco
rules? I would love to.
At at some point, we introduced the rules
so that we can detect whether or not
your cluster is mining some Bitcoins.
Right? At
that point,
to detect if we were mining Bitcoins,
the only way
that we had
was I mean, because, you know, a Bitcoin
miner what does a Bitcoin miner do? Right?
I mean, they are all different. A very
common thing that they do is that they
connect to a miner pool
to, you know,
exchange keys and, you know, say, yeah. Yeah.
I miner this. I miner that. Do I
need tokens?
And
so what we did, we created a rule
that connects to minor pools
to figure out their IP address
so that we can
filter out the IP address for rules. At
some point, people start opening issues of Falco
is connected to minor pools.
It's a minor,
and Falco was not really a minor. But
that was a good idea, honestly, because, know,
you can make some millions.
We were probably on an island somewhere.
Yeah.
Yeah. Well, I guess That would be very
cool. Yeah. If you're working on security software
that helps people there on that stuff. It's
also the best backdoor, though, where you could
just go and make all the crypto you
want. So why not?
Okay.
So We don't do that. No. Of course
not. We're We're we're good people. So
we have Falco running on all of these
machines.
We can see right away that we're getting
output to our system d log that tells
us when bad things are happening.
Is the next step now to hook up
the Kubernetes audit log, or is there something
else that you you wanna show off just
from this setup that we have? Before
we dive into that, I would love to
just say something to the audience just for,
you know, completeness.
Because you installed Falco
in,
you know, with APT in all your machines.
Right? And, you know, in a real production
environment,
what you will do
is to, you know, put the Falco logs
somewhere or be able to, you know, at
at least see them in a way that
it's not SSH in the machine. So Falco
has some constructs to do that that you
can use. Falco can write logs to either
a file or to the CS log or
to To another program. It can be like
you're doing to other program.
It can use a it can it has
a gRPC server where it can connect where
it can connect with the g r p
with a go or rust or a Python
client that are already there. So you can,
you know, integrate that into, you know, your
stream log stream pipeline.
Or,
you know, we have a software in the
Falco security organization which is called Falco Sidekick
that, you know, for example, can take,
the Falco logs and send them to Slack
or send them to AWS SNS or these
kind things. So in a production environment, you
will have also that piece
that, you know, strings along somewhere
so that you can analyze them, for example.
Right? But that's, you know, not something that
we do, like, in this
session.
Yeah. That makes sense. Very
good for that.
Okay. Cool. Oh, let's go with the audit.
Yep.
Okay.
What what does that mean?
Yeah. Oh, so we said that we have
a Falco web server.
Right?
The first thing that you can try to
do
is to actually send
event ourself. Like, let's pretend that you are
Kubernetes. Right? And we want to trigger an
event to Falco.
I'm sending the comment to you because we
don't want to figure it to figure that
out.
Give me a second. Yeah. Sure.
Okay.
So
I like the sound of your switches.
I don't know if it can I send
Jason in this private chat?
Yeah. Sure. It'll work.
It should work.
Okay. This is an event. You should just
save it to
you just copy the command and save it
to a file.
Are we sure it has not been
trunk truncated,
Laura? Oh, maybe yes. It has. I I
can I can send a guest? Maybe Yeah.
Sure. Yeah.
Share a guest.
I I knew. I knew. I I should
have done this before.
Things dot txt
and then this.
Alright.
Alright. Here's my guest. Great.
So just a guest, it tests two comments
in a file name, things update txt.
And the first one creates
just do them one by one because we
need to
the first one is creates a file sample
event dot JSON. So what happens when the
Kubernetes
when Kubernetes sends audit log is that it
it just takes an endpoint with some JSON.
Right?
And, like, surprising, it's not the YAML.
So
it send this event,
and the event here should trigger
Falco
a Falco rule
described in Kate's audit rule YAML,
and you shall see it in the Falco
log. This is just to confirm that, you
know, Falco
is configured correctly,
and it's working
to accept Falco Kubernetes audit event should be,
like that by default.
But we just, you know, want to see
an event before we configure
of Kubernetes itself to send them so that
we don't think, hey. It's it's, it's Falco
that's not accepting event or something like that.
So then you can do the cool command
sent to you.
Okay. So this is just gonna send
that to Yes. The Falco web server? Yeah.
This, yeah, opens the sample event event JSON
file and just sends it to the case,
add it, and says, okay.
And you can now
yeah. We have to improve it. And you
can now return our CTL,
and it says, warning request by anonymous users.
Allowed
a verb. Create
API need spaces.
So
this is how an audit log that triggers
a rule looks like. And you could open
the rule file for the create Savvy logs
and see
the actual The re this rule one, request
by anonymous user.
Exactly.
Okay. So we'll It's very cool because that
when you have Falco ops, you can also
at some point, you cannot start ignoring them.
No.
It's the other it's the other file, the
file named gates underscore auditor.
Exactly.
Yes?
Exactly. So
the rule the rule sees it's a Kubernetes
event,
and the username is system anonymous.
And it their authentication was allowed. And, you
know, anonymous authentication should not be allowed in
your clusters.
And this is not manages to do that.
Yeah.
And this is to match the SYS benchmarks.
There's a CIS benchmark
one one one that
we I mean, every time a c I
CIS benchmark
comes out or a courtesy CV comes out,
we try to update the rules files both
for Kubernetes audit and both for the Ciscos
to
make sure that we are there from that
behavior.
Alright. Awesome.
If we find the email for the CV.
So I'm just processing in my head. So
we actually without
enabling any of the kubelet flags, we we
just showed that the Kubernetes stuff works. Right?
Like, we Yeah. We created a Kubernetes
JSON,
and then we just send it to Falco
directly.
And Yeah. This event, of course, didn't really
happen in Kubernetes. It's just that we simulate
it.
We can now go and edit the the
Kubernetes API server flags
and configure it with the,
the
with the audit log path, audit policy file,
and audit webhook config file.
And in the Falco evolution repository,
we have an audit policy
that you can pass.
But that is basically how you configure Kubernetes
for, you know, sending events on endpoint.
The for Falco, the dynamic
webhook
feature
that existed in Kubernetes,
like, eight
up until 01/18 was very useful.
But, you know, it got dropped, so everyone
who needs to configure
their Kubernetes cluster needs to do this manual
step, which is something that you are working
on, you're removing,
if it's even feasible for us.
But every cluster is different. You might not
have, you know, cluster.
You might have a cluster from a distribution
that doesn't do the same things in that
way. So it's just, you know, just configuring
the other log. So where is your API
server flags,
file?
Yep.
Kubernetes
No worries. One step at time. Server.
Container d.
I did look this up, and I have
drawn a blank. Let's see.
Oh, before before you, you know, start changing
it on every node, we should just also
download the audit policy file.
Yeah. Go to
github.com/falcosecurity/evolutionexamplefolderevolution.Evolution.
Yeah. Okay.
Yeah. It's like a bug.
I think I've looked at this.
Yeah. Go go yeah. One app. Yes. Auditing
policy. Yeah. More. Okay.
Yeah. We have a good extension to do
this here, but we are trying to do
it without looking at it.
Okay. So you want me to copy all
of this?
Yeah. Just download this file in all your
notes. Yeah. Do get this file or do
get as you prefer. In a place where
you feel like you can leave it there.
Like, for example,
I don't know, ATC Falco over
Okay.
So broadcast
w get
Broadcast. Yes.
I'm broadcasting some we are broadcasting a broadcast.
Oh my gosh. Etcetera.
I'll just start here.
Yeah.
Yep. I should have
auto policy. Good. Very good. You don't have
to configure it because it's actually,
you know, set it up to
to
the default things, which should be good.
And now we need the web config
for
to pass to Kubernetes, which should should also
be there,
but they can drop it in the guest.
This one here?
Yeah.
That one.
Exactly. Yeah. We have to change Falco service
cluster IP to local 127001.
Yep.
Okay.
This is just something I'm going to apply
to the cluster. Right?
No. This is something that you still pass
it to the Kubernetes API server.
To the to the flags.
We need to pass to the Kubernetes API
server two files, the audit policy file and
the audit web book config.
And What?
Also the audit log file.
Yeah. And also the other log file if
you want to save the logs of file
too.
Okay. That's great. Yep. That was good.
So what's next? We have to add the
the API server flags. Right? Exactly. Edit API
server flags.
Alright. So let me find the status.
Let let's over this. Go ahead and discuss
our stats again after we do this.
It it will.
It looks like it's being controlled by the
Can you edit them via the cluster API
thing that you did, or you can't? I'm
not sure. I could, but we'd have to
wait for that to roll the changes out.
Yeah. Just my curiosity. I don't want to
do it. I mean, I'm scared already. But
Okay. So Kubernetes
manifest,
cube API server.
Alright. Okay. We got what we need here.
So
That's cool. So the flags are But we
wanted to do that on all of them.
So let me
Kubernetes
manifests
cube
API server. Okay.
Yeah. So the flags that you have to
add are
are developer I
think that's
I've got
something. Let me let me copy them in
the chat, probably.
Oh, yeah. Sure. Go for it.
I think they are in documentation too, but,
I mean, I hope they are.
Well, the first one should be this one,
dash epic server dash shark equal audit policy
file.
And then the other is about the workbook
config file.
Yeah. Just change audit policy file with the
if you copy the net c file. I
don't remember where you copied it. Yeah. I'm
I'm writing the comments in the private chat.
You've already done it for me. Perfect. Thank
you, Leo.
You're welcome.
Those file there, or they are in Etsy
Falco? I don't remember. Alright. Etsy. They
are in Etsy, not Etsy Falco. Okay. So
we're adding two Kube API server arguments. One
of them is audit policy file, which goes
to the YAML file we got from the
Sysdig repository, the evolution repository. No. I I
need I wait. Wait. Wait. This is wrong.
We have to remove Kube API server arg
and just leave
dash dash eight audit policy file. Right. Yes.
Yes. Yeah. Of course.
So dash dash.
Yeah. Exactly. Yeah. This was for
k three s k three s. Okay.
So we're at an audit policy, audit web
config, and those go to the two YAML
files.
Done.
Exactly.
And then restart our
System CTL.
Demo load.
So these are running in the cluster
because they're static manifest. So if I just
run get pods dash a
Oh, nice.
You really broke it?
I broke it. We have broke it.
Alright. Alright. So the static manifest that this
change would have been detected by the kubelet
as then restarted them. So let's jump over
to one of them and find out what
is going on here.
So
I
Very cool. I know that we will have
broken it. Yeah. We have no no API.
Doesn't work.
No.
Let's just confirm the two paths. So we
said we had a webhook.YAML.
Okay. Probably Yeah. We're passing There's no webhook
config. It's .com. It's webhookYAML.
It's only webhookYAML. I will rename the file,
honestly. Easy fix. So
k.
And then by magic,
this is gonna come back any
second there. It's gonna come back. Are you
sure? I don't know. Don't know. It's still
Kubernetes.
And also Falco.
So
Let's restart our Kubelet.
Alright. So something's still
failing. So okay. So let's just confirm.
We have webhook.catyamo.
And we have Yes.
Auditpolicy.yamo
with a dash,
which is
auditpolicy.yaml.
Okay. Those are just Are both yaml or
y m l?
Good question.
Too many tabs. Too many tabs.
One more.
Yeah. .Ya
yeah. They're okay. And do we have any
logs from the API server, like,
anywhere? Yes.
So varlog
containers.
Let's get our to the Qtube API server.
Which one is the most recent?
This
one here.
Okay. So auditpolicy.YAML
does not No such file of that. So
the name is not that.
Alright. Audit.
It's the same user.
Okay. So, yes. Here's the challenge. Right? This
is a static manifest.
So
we need to move that file, don't we?
Maybe.
We do. So let's look at the mode
points. Let's just open.
Oh, yes. Because this is in the container.
It's not the right.
Oh, right. Very good. I I love this.
I
hate it. But, anyway, so let's
so we need share the
Oh, I need to do this in everything.
Right? So
Oh, it's very very good. Now so if
the Kubernetes is not on there, it will
not be able to just talk to Falco
via +1 270001
also.
Shall we switch over to the backup cluster?
Or do you wanna or shall we stick
with this?
As you prefer.
Fine. Do do.
You are David.
I'm just worried. So
Okay. So let me explain the problem then
to the people that are watching. What's happening
here is our API server is running inside
of a container and not on a host.
The challenge with that is these two files
exist on the host file system. Now what
we can do is modify the main points
at the bottom. And if we do that,
the API server will start. But then Falco
still has to speak.
Does Falco speak to the API server or
the Kubelet?
API server, but we can I think that
we can figure it out? Right. Let's do
it. So let's just I'm gonna move both
of these files to somewhere that is a
bit more friendly. So let's call this our
Falco
two. That's horrible naming.
No. Yeah. I'll do that. API server.
And let's move our web hook and our
audit fail into the API server.
Let's modify our static manifest now
and add that as a mount point.
So cube API server, jump down the bottom.
Let's add a new volume,
host path.
Mhmm.
Path slash etcetera API server
and type
directory
or create
a name
API server config.
Now we can go to volume mounts.
Mount path,
etcetera,
API server.
Read only true.
And we need the name which I called
API.
API server config. I I love how you
remember all the
Alright. So that is gonna make that available.
Now we've one more change to make in
this file, which is those arguments.
So instead of here is etcetera,
API server,
API
server.
Oh, wait. Right?
I also think that we need to change
the
The IP address in
yeah. So it's advertising on the host IP.
So we can just change.
So we should be okay. And we can
fix that anyway if we need to.
What happened on these machines?
We'll just ignore it.
No. That's a static manifest
which has now been reapplied.
I'm gonna feel brave.
Because you can get notes. Yeah.
Yes. Party.
Party online long. It's less notes than before,
but should be It's okay. No. It's I
was joking.
So we got our API server running with
our Falco and audit integrations. We can celebrate,
but that's only step one. So next,
can we confirm that Falco can speak to
the API server?
Yeah. Let's open the Falco logs in one
of the the
in one of the nodes, and then we
can try to do something evil
and see what Falco thinks about that.
Yeah.
I see Kubernetes stuff.
Yeah. So It's working. It seems to be
working. It seems. Let's now try. Yes. It's
working.
Yeah. I'm joking. We knew it was gonna
work. Right? We knew. It's fine.
I sent you a call, man. You can
try to create
a config map with the credential for, like,
an AWS his an AWS access key.
Okay. So I For example
Well, yeah. Over to
here. So this is me speaking to our
cluster. We're creating a conflict map. We're calling
AWS creds, and we're giving it something that
looks like a secret. Right? Remove the backslash.
Yeah.
After
AWS
threads. Yeah. Oh, oh, yep.
Yeah.
Yes. So this should alert
all the Falco instances
at some point.
It depends on which instance
are you locking the
Ah,
Okay.
So if I can't Try try to get
logs again.
No. Or
or maybe just went into sea into the
sea of the logs.
So where do you want me to look?
Sorry.
We we want to see or or maybe
it's not in this rule set that things
I want to trigger.
Okay. So we can check that as well.
Right? So Yeah. If we do Kubernetes
rules
Yes. I'm assuming if I search for secret
AWS.
Yes. Oh, AWS rule.
Okay. So we have a macro at least.
I'm saying private credentials.
Yes.
And we do have a rule that uses
the macro as a condition here.
I believe that there's some other rule that
it's
because the way
events are triggered
is that if the an event triggers
a rule first,
you're not going to see the other. So
probably the way you create things
is triggering the rules first. Like, maybe it's
triggering someone
some privileged user,
the other the the other rule that you're
seeing, right,
if you show me the logs.
Yes? Okay. So we wanna look at the
Falco logs again. Right?
Yep.
Yes. The cluster
binding cluster binding cluster. Yeah. That's a lot
of stuff.
There's a there's a lot. Maybe it's even
before these ones. Yeah. I think I want
to see
the
you did journal CTL x a f.
Let's try You, Falco.
Okay. Let's have a look at it this
way.
I verified below.
There's a lot. There's a lot.
Let's see if I warning pods sensitive file
open.
Warning pod file. Yeah. There's a lot of
stuff. Let me turn off the pager.
Maybe grep for Grep for com AWS.
Oh,
AWS.
No. It didn't show up
for some reason. Maybe that.
I don't know. So can I just understand
what's going on here? Right? Because currently, I
am on the control plane node. Should all
of the Falco's be alerted to this secret
creation?
That's
a very good question. It should not be
like that
because you don't have the API server on
on all nodes, but you have to manifest
on all nodes.
So we have to go to the active
master then. Right? Exactly.
I thought you were in the active master.
Well, when we restarted the API server, I
have no idea which one picked it up,
so we need to look.
Okay. Cool. Okay. So if I take a
look here, let's see if I can see
the IP address.
Because they're only the masters that they create
that they send the events. Right?
So this one actually potentially is the master,
but what I will do is open the
other two.
And If you still get notes dash all
wide should should be useful.
Okay.
Get note.
Get notes all wide.
Let's just grab these IPs.
Or maybe it doesn't work. Right? Just
It does work. I know it works. We
just need to find the correct API server.
Now that I know how it's working, I'm
I'm confident we can get the logs. Okay?
You can insert your password with your fingerprint.
Yeah. SE key is fantastic.
Amazing.
Or or if you're on Linux, there's a
similar one too.
But I have to use Mac as my
new role, which I'm hoping changes soon.
There we go. Yeah.
I
knew it worked. I mean, I didn't dream
it.
I mean Right. We tried this, like, ten
hours ago,
so nothing changed in Falco in the past
ten ten hours. So
Alright. That was One good one good improvement
to Falco that we could do is we
don't print out the credential
logs. Yeah. I mean,
otherwise, the this is
very useful. So But this is a rule
change. It's not a software change.
Like, the person that made the rule
explicitly
decide to print out the credential.
Yep.
So it's not
so maybe we can we can make a
longer change that if we if we find
the credential, we just hide it, but it's
a bit more complicated than that.
Okay. So that was really cool. I'm gonna
try and summarize this. Right? So we modified
the API server on our control plane with
two flags, audit policy and audit webhook.
We injected some pre canned configs that we
got from
the Falco repository,
that's evolution repository here. Yep. So we just
copy and pasted that. We don't really do
anything else except change the
change the Falco IP just to be local
host. And by that, we get all of
the Kubernetes events going to Falco where the
rules kicked in, detected a privacy
and logged that. Now we had a better
struggle finding that, but normally in a production
scenario,
that would be getting centralized anyway. I'd see
that in Elasticsearch.
I'd see that in Splunk. I'd see that
wherever I'm storing all my logs and that
would be visible front and center.
That's awesome. So,
yeah, in a normal production scenario or in
a development because, you know, development machine only
have one Kubernetes node. In a production scenario,
you have the centralized locking.
So when this kind of when you do
this kind of demos, you'll never remember that
kind of details.
But Yeah. I should have spun up a
single master control plane. I I probably went
a little bit over the top with my
HD setup. But A little just a little
bit. It's very cool to see how you
over engineered this demo. Yeah. You should see
how many cores I've got on this thing
and how much RAM as well for a
cluster I'm spinning up for an hour.
But that's the joy of bare metal. Like,
it's great how much power I can throw
at this.
Right? Anyways, David, since we are since you
mentioned the evolution repository, I think it's could
be useful for the audience and people interested
in Falco
to know that this repo evolution is
a simple repo where we basically
try to keep all the
things
the getting started guides
for users. For example, you can find here
examples manifest for
deploying your first Falco in your Kubernetes.
So
there were also m charts here, then later
we will bring the in the charts repository.
Various examples, third party integrations,
things like that can be very useful for
people that just want that loves to approach
a new a new project just by trying
it without having to study all the
the moving pieces of Falco.
Without a PhD in a for.
Alright. So I'll add that to the show
notes. This this repository is definitely worth checking
it then for anyone that is gonna start
playing with Falco. Excellent.
Is
there anything else you wanna show off, cover,
after that before we finish up for this
afternoon? Is there anything that we've not covered
that makes sense? Oh, yeah. That's the thing.
Go to Falcosecurity/
p dig.
Yep. And that's also in BPF if we
want to. Because we run Falcon now with
the current model, not with BPF probe. Okay.
Yeah. Maybe we don't want to run to
restart Falco to run with BPF for now.
So sorry. What what what should I go
to here?
I I just want maybe to talk for
ten seconds about our user space efforts
for
with the pdig repo.
Search for pdig.
Oh, pdig.
Thank you. Yeah. P dig. P dig. Yes.
So,
just a very underrepresented repository in our community.
But For now. For now. Yes. So
we we told about the fact that we,
you know, either run with a kind of
module or a BPF probe. Right? And
that's a very good thing, you know, to
have, like, because, you know, you can start
kind of modules that you can use in
a BPF probe. But that doesn't work in
every environment.
Yeah. For example,
words are very good on bare metal,
but, like, it doesn't work on sandbox environments.
For example, if you put that, you know,
on
Fargate environment or something like that, I just
the only one that came in mind.
Or you put, like, on a device or
or on something like that.
So you need something that doesn't rely on
you know?
The possibility for to assess the the kernel.
Yeah.
And so we started working on an interface,
which is the user space
API,
which is not very well documented yet because
it's just a ring buffer in memory that's
shared between processes.
But that one allows us to send events
input events to Falco,
and one implementation of that is PDG.
So PDG just uses p trace to send
events to Falco. It's not as performant as
Falco,
as the Falco kind of module. It's not
as performant as the eBPF probe, but it's
a way to show that Falco can accept
different
kind of events coming from different sources
that are not just, you know, those two
that we are deploying production right now.
And,
also, this open, you know, a world of
possibility for different kind of devices,
like, you know, you want to play Falco
on Mac OS or
Windows, something like that,
you have an interface.
And you can to different kind of inputs.
Maybe maybe you could
our our goal here is to create in
the future, we are working
on a an interface so that the community
can create, for example,
another inputs for Falco that this time is
not Kubernetes audit logs, but some some other
kind of audit logs
without naming names.
I don't know. But just,
or
other other kind of events,
whatever.
And so,
in that in that way, user then could
write will be able to write rules
to to detect
even
some events and trigger alerts on some events
depending
on this new input.
I I found this
I found this useful when I was trying
to make Falco work on Arch 64.
I was using
Equinix
for starting a very beefy machine
because, you know, I had some I I
didn't really have a Raspberry Pi. I didn't
want to wait
for it to compile Falco because it already
takes
a lot of time.
Like, you compile open SSL and other things.
So, it takes a lot of time. And
you don't want to wait. So I just
started that machine, but then I didn't have
a driver because our kind of modular VPF
Pro are not made for r 64.
They are made for x 86.
We ported that to r 64 now. But
when I want to just, you know, see,
hey. This thing works,
I was kind of I can just use
PD because it's not,
I can just use the user space interface
because it's not architecture dependent.
And, you know, that will work about very
well. For so also for, you know, porting
to new architectures.
Nice.
That's it. This is a very cool improvement
that we did over the last year.
I mean, thanks to the whole team and
overall to Lawrence, which actually made the code
happen.
Awesome. That's cool. That's good that people have
that choice then depending on the environment that
they're running. They still got an option to
instrument and understand their applications using Falco or
that's awesome. Nice one. So we have a
couple more comments. Our mutual friend, says,
Ciao. Hi. And
we got a question from,
is there a GUI?
I mean, I'm happy to give you what
I think the answer is, and then you
two can correct me if you were to.
Yeah. Please. I'm gonna assume there there's no
GUI. From what I understand of what you've
you've explained to me today about Falco is
that it's a detection system that events,
and we should be storing those events somewhere
where we have the ability to query them
and notify on them and alert on them.
And that may be something like Elasticsearch,
and FoxDB, or even just Sesslog.
But from there would be the interface. Is
that is that correct?
Exactly.
Yeah. The the answer is correct. There's a
GUI which is commercial,
which is developed by Sysdig,
but it's not, you know, Falco. It's, you
know, a product of Sysdig, which is called
Sysdig Secure, which also has a query for
Falco. Yeah. But it's just you know, they're
it's one of their additional values on top
of Falco.
I want to I want to be clear
with the audience here.
Since they paid us a salary, I don't
know why, honestly, but
but Falco
is a CNCF incubated project that plans to
graduate next year,
and that's being donated to the CNCF.
Maybe we missed a bit of history of
Falco, so let me just be brief about
it. But Falco's graduated was sent back in
02/2018,
was initially started at Falco in 02/2016 as
an open source project.
But after that, it has been donated to
CNCF. Basically, we are CNCF maintainers,
which means that
since the engineering in any way can interfere
with the plans that we have with Falco,
which is, by the way, something that I
love because it means that I can do
whatever the hell I want.
So,
yes, there's a commercial GUI. The probably, are
also other commercial GUIs
and that will be out there.
But this is not a problem for the
Falco maintainers,
for Falco community Exactly. Because
our goal is to make Falco
consumable
by the cloud native community,
and this is the reason that we are
working on APIs for rules that that watches
rules
that can changes, APIs for user space inputs,
and things like that to make it more
inter integrated with the the whole cloud native
ecosystem.
That's the goal. Sweet. So to summarize that
again,
you should be responsible for storing the events
wherever you want and visualize them that way.
But if you wanna support further development of
Sysdig and their time to work on this
continually
and you're happy to pay, you should look
into Sysdig Secure, which does it all for
you. That sounds awesome.
And, of course Yeah. Or or you can
pay someone else that does the same thing,
but it just just
because Susie made a product out of it.
Alright. Well, I just wanna say thank you
to both of you. This has been a
very great learning experience for me as even
though we had a couple of small challenges,
we overcome it. We've seen Falco running on
our bare Linux system and side of our
Kubernetes cluster. We saw those events. They're gonna
help me provide secure platforms for my Kubernetes
stuff. So that's awesome. Thank you again for
joining me. Thanks, David. Any closing thoughts before
I before we say goodbye? Yeah. I'll be
all set up, David, and your music.
Me too. I also have another another thought.
Don't we have five minutes to try VPS
driver?
I'm joking. I
don't think we do.
I'm I'm just joking.
We can always have another session. Don't worry,
Luca. We we can come back anytime you
want and look at more stuff here. We
can have a session on debugging why the
PPI driver doesn't work on Keras 5.9.
With Clang 10 or things like that. Okay.
Let's do it.
Do you have GDP on your Mac installed
and everything?
We'll figure it out. Not today. Alright.
Thanks again. Have an absolute great day, and
I'll speak to you both. Thanks for inviting
us. Thanks for asking us. Cheers. Bye bye.
Ciao. Bye bye.